[Music]
welcome to the interval thanks everybody
for coming out tonight how about a big
round of applause for the exciting
evening we have ahead of us my name is
Michael M I'm the producer of this
series at the interval thank you I've
lost track at the moment of how many of
these talks that we've done now but
every single one of them has been full
to the brim just like tonight and that
makes any event better and we're so
appreciative of you for responding to
this series for coming out to it it's we
have a great talk for you and it's even
better to have this much excitement and
a great crowd like you tonight so thank
you for being here the Internet Archive
are our friends of long now our partners
at law now because they're helping us
with our manual for civilization project
if you've heard about the books that we
are collecting the list of books that we
would need to help restart civilization
the digital versions of those books are
going to be available as we continue to
build that collection on the Internet
Archive we collaborate with them on a
bunch of things including with our
rosetta project but they're more than
that they're actually our old roommates
so so back in the day before we got this
this space and if you don't know the
interval has only existed in this form
for less than a year at this point but
we we took it over as a much more modest
space in 2006 a former museum space
before that we were sharing a house as
it were in the Presidio with the the
Internet Archive and we've both moved on
and moved up in the world with larger
families of and large larger groups
working for us in much cooler digs they
are now at a former on a former church
that is amazing so a big welcome for the
Internet Archive folks who are spread
all amongst you and thank you support
them and and appreciate them cuz they're
an amazing resource
[Applause]
Jason Scott is is working for all of us
he is preserving the the the the memory
and the the artifacts of the first
networked world that that has led to so
many more things that we do online today
he's continuing to think about the
present content even when it's
threatened by the folks who nominally
own it and helping to keep it for future
generations we talk about being good
ancestors and Jason is helping all of us
to do that by making sure that the
things we're making today the things
we're playing with yesterday are
available to folks in the future give a
big round of applause for the
best-dressed man in the house please mr.
Jason Scott hello everyone hi everybody
how you doing Aloha hi there okay so
this talk is called webinar blink but
it's of course a lot about a person and
it's a lot about us as people and
everything else I don't know just just
just go like this for a seconds and
nobody knows it's you how many people
have not actually seen something where
I'm talking before and are just here
because you're good people excellent I
like that it always a it always amazes
me because life is so busy now and so
directed that we're all used to just
ending up in echo chambers of watching
the same thing over and over again and a
binge watch so I'm always impressed with
people who are like I on that it might
be fun let's go that's amazing to me so
thank you very much for having that
outlook and for everyone else who has to
hear me come over the sound of their
office constantly saying the same 14
things over and over again I thank all
of you for coming here as well because
that's pretty involved itself so all
right so the talk is called like I said
what webinar I blink and my name is
Jason Scott I'm about 44 years old I
give talks I collect things I'll talk a
little bit about what I'm up to what
we're when I'm
believing and what I'm doing and and
also I just want to say that that um a
lot of what I do is gain attention and
if my clothing doesn't really indicate
that it's because I I just believe that
you know we are surrounded by so much
noise and that unfortunately loud weird
squeaky wheels with a feather in their
hat tend to get the attention and my
hope is that the things that I care
about and that I want people know about
are worthy of their attention right and
I was very very affected by a speech by
someone named Wilson minor and you're
totally allowed not know who else in
minor was he worked for Facebook for a
while but I'm sure he'll make up for
that in the stretch of time and he gave
a couple talks that were very
fascinating because they struck at the
heart of what a talk is I've given about
a hundred talks and you know the problem
is a lot of talks just end up being a
show and tell about some basic concept
that you then have to spend 45 minutes
being told the paragraph worth of text
and Wilson actually did this amazing
thing where he built a tool on stage or
he showed a tool on stage that everyone
wanted but it wasn't about the tool it
was actually about his philosophy so I'm
gonna show you some things but I think
that the point of a presentation is that
it's not a piece of paper that someone
just slowly drags their finger across
for an hour but that it should actually
be a series of strings that a person
holds out to you one after another with
a tag on them and you go what was that
and yank it and spend the next afternoon
trying to find out more about that thing
so I've had myself in a bunch of places
and like I said I'm an attention-getter
so um like this is just me at some
Improv anywhere stunts where everybody
like 500 people dressed up in tuxedos
and went to Coney Island Beach in the
middle of the day um looks good in the
business card but I've also been known
over the years for a whole bunch of
crazy jobs things and stuff that I've
done at 44 each one of these is a story
in itself and I've you know been a lot
of things but it's always that last one
because people like are you a famous cat
owner are you a famous cat owner what
the hell is up with that
and oh yeah okay fine but most of like I
said it's about walking around getting
in people's faces but I always want to
leave a few more questions than I answer
so we'll go into some of those always
wear a viking hat when you visit iceland
by the way it really works out
the natives appreciate it they really
think it's funny if they've never seen
it before it blows their minds that a
guy would stand and rekha Vic with a
anyway so but so I have this famous cat
and the cat's name is socking ttan and
socking tonie's famous because he has
one point four million Twitter followers
and so whenever anybody brags about
their Twitter followers just remind them
that a house cat has one point four
million when this happened in 2007 and
the sand this cat jettisoned up and
became kind of the center of the world
for a very short period of time it was a
weird little story it really helped me
understand the arbitrariness and
meaningless Ness of celebrity right
because the thing was was I was on the
phone with someone from the Today Show
screaming at me about why my cat needed
to go on the air with them and if I
wasn't gonna do that god damn it do not
go over to ABC and I'm driving with this
person I mean she's begging you know and
she's telling me I'm like the cat will
have a heart attack this this cat is
were recovered stray he has no idea it's
gonna be very hard to explain to my cat
what's happening why he's being loaded
into a plane to go into a loud room full
of shouting people while somebody talks
to to his owner who he hates by the way
and and like that I just want to be
clear that is not the face of a cat
that's like I appreciate this and this
is fantastic that is a cat literally
waiting for the food bowl or for my face
to get within viewing range
it's hopeless it's like having a like a
bee outfit just making sure that this
cat he's beautiful but he's also really
doesn't like me so and she was like
willing to have me sedate the cat I mean
she was like really really on it and and
I got interviewed I said anyone who
comes to the house can interview me so
so an ABC affiliate came to the house
and interviewed me and he got everywhere
and and as someone pointed out I mean
socks at that point had
hundred thousand followers and the
astronaut twittering from space at
400,000 and it was just funny to me
because it was all very people were
trying to find the meaning you know this
is what it's about
why and they didn't realize that just
the world is full of dumb things and we
like shiny weird stupid stuff and it's
not always based on merit and it's kind
of based on on yourself okay so so when
every time you like really feel like
what you're working on and people aren't
paying attention would just remember
they're all looking at the twittering
cat on his Twitter his Twitter account
because you know he needs more followers
is socking ton and and yeah it's exactly
what you think it is it's cat who's
constantly ever ever on edge and angry
at the world I will say one more thing
about him which was that Garfield Oh
Garfield join one day but only had like
2,000 followers so socks was talking to
him like he was like Justin Bieber and
Keith Richards had gotten on the bus and
be like Oh Garfield I've always admired
your work you're so awesome and the
Garfield account was responding which I
thought was funny and then one day he
declared tuna is everything and Starkist
wrote back truth all right so anyway
Brant brand engagement with cats
all right anyway so jason has young
fellow so there's me on the right that's
my brother with no pants that's my great
uncle sam and so yeah so I was born and
I'm gonna tell you about some stuff in
my childhood that was awful but I just
want to show you that on the other end I
came out pretty okay so this is me at 17
I'm pretty well adjusted right here I
have a whole bunch of stuff that I stole
in my yearbook photo oh yeah no no I
bought that phone
I'm sure anyway alright so yeah yeah
sorry I bought that phone oh I bought
that highway sign I bought anyway so um
not one but two highway flashers I just
want to point out just couldn't anyway
this is my yearbook photo can you
believe that anyway all right all right
all right right right so people always
try to go like well what's the moment
that really kind of defines you and
really kind of changes your outlook on
life and and for me that's about when
I'm
when I'm about nine the reason I'm I
always look back on that is because I
was woken up by my mother and I had a
brother and a sister at the time and my
father was sick in the hospital and my
mother said we have to go
my mother had decided that my father was
dangerous I've spent 30 years with a man
since then I disagree with the diagnosis
but I was nine but she decided she
wanted to pull the kids out of the house
at about 10 o'clock at night and so what
she said to me was grab what you think
you need which is an incredible thing to
ask a nine-year-old turns out a
nine-year-old needs a blanket and his
dog but that was my boiling down of my
life at that point I really liked rocky
and I really liked that blanket rich
rich shade of blue blue still my
favorite color and the thing is is we
pulled away and it took that about three
weeks to figure out where we were during
which he lost about 50 pounds actually
and so it was this very stressful
situation in our lives the parents did
not get back together again
and I learned some very very odd weird
lessons that are my own personal lessons
that came in right which was nothing is
permanent trust very little and you are
responsible for your destiny you know in
other words I realized that even if my
my parents marriage and the home I lived
in was all gonna be you know once you
listen you have enough people who they
come in through life and you know they
can always go home and I couldn't I was
going to go now live in a series of
weird apartments and different schools
and everything else and I went to like
something like six schools I think
totally before I graduated from high
school so you know you move around you
gotta be responsible for your own
destiny is what I learned okay so this
explains why I fell in love with worlds
that were outside my own right so I'm
you know when you make your dad pull
over so you can pose with the Apple sign
at 11:00 right and notice that I've got
sunglasses on because that just ups it
right you're you're so cool and subtle
you just happen to be leaning on the
Apple sign this was the first time I
ever gone to California and I loved
California because California was a
dream in my head of this beautiful warm
place I'm from New York some people hear
my voice and go yeah duh but okay so I'm
I'm from New York and then I went to I
thought my accent was just a little bit
too smooth and rich so I went to Boston
for 20 years
mixed them together and this is what you
got I'm sorry and so I lived in New York
and we went to California and I just I
just love that and I think this isn't
mine but I think that's something I
really learned was you know what I love
about this picture here and here's what
I love so much is um he's gone ahead and
he's drawn all of the favorite logos of
companies who make video games and
computers and he's drawn them in his
book of his Atari you know he's had to
like put the Atari thing in a binder
he's written where he's from and he's
got all the different games over on the
left he's got the some drawings of like
pinouts and everything else and more
important to me this picture was then
taken 30 years after the notebook came
out right so he not only lived this and
loved it but 30 years later he still had
it see so one of the things I'm always
trying to fight is this idea that like
technology is a cold weird thing or that
mass-produced items whether it's a
blender a car or computer are simply
dead things within themselves like the
humans once they get their hands on the
things love the things and their love of
the things make these things come alive
so there is a benefit in collecting
things right because there's a part of
you that comes in there it becomes part
of the story of your life the story you
tell it becomes the talisman and and
here's the thing right so when I was in
my teens I started calling computer
bulletin board systems and I loved them
I racked up incredible amounts of bills
this is another yearbook photo where I
am posing with my BBS so yeah that's
right and you're like wow Jason you also
have some weird stuff in there yes
cryptographic message how to make
chicken littles from a KFC that one of
my friends worked at Lysol there's a
whole thing with there's a whole thing
with shop-vacs
and that's why that's their the
Dustbuster I made sure that I had a
Dustbuster and every photo of me in the
yearbook I don't know sometimes I think
like there just be this glowing door and
I come out I go what are you thinking
and then they leave again no advice no
nothing just stop it but you know anyway
dustbusters love them um but the thing
was was when I call bulletin board
systems and I'm assuming people know
what a bulletin board system is a
bulletin board system is basically a
computer with a modem with a lonely
person at it who then keeps code up so
that when other lonely people call them
they leave messages about how angry they
are at the world cuz they're lonely and
then other people disagree with them and
nobody gives anybody a hug and anyway so
the point is that these things were kind
of self-made worlds right you would you
would pay about some money at the time
to put a computer on a phone line I mean
this is all very expensive and then
other people would call and use your
computer and post it but the thing was
is that they were transient right they
were unbelievably transient they would
go away after like five six months and
and some of them would stay around for a
year - or disappear Jason who had
previously learned that the world was
messed up would back up everything he
found so if I found anything on the
website that I liked that uh told me
about the place or had quote-unquote
text files where you could go and find
out how to make a bomb how to fix the
modem how to angry at the world
ten terrible lightbulb jokes I just
grabbed them all right I just grabbed
them all put them all on floppy disks
until I had a stack of floppy disks and
when bulletin board systems stopped
being important in my life okay that's
not right
when bulletin board systems stopped
being a thing I did daily I ended up
going to you know college and I found a
way to gone through MIT system into the
Internet at like 18 or 19 and you know
once you once you're doing you know the
heroin go back to the marijuana and so I
ended up storing away those floppies and
in 1998 I thought man I sure had fun on
those BBS's and now I'm 28 and the web
is up and the web has everything now
it's got Alta Vista it's it's pretty
it's got lots of the text will Center
now you can affect the font um
sky's the limit so let me go look up
about my favorite bulletin board system
share wood forest nine one four three
five nine one five one seven and let's
go find out what's going on with them no
information that's weird
how about bulletin board systems of New
York nothing ooh how about bulletin
board systems not much all right what
happened here now friggin twenty years
of research has revealed to be what
happened I'll tell you in a moment it's
not that interesting but basically
bulletin board systems were persona non
grata on internet and so I was like but
I have all these old text files well
while I put them all up so so I ended up
grabbing text files calm and I put up 50
thousand text files that I collected
over those years and all these people
came out of the woodwork to go first oh
my god all these old things and more
importantly I have stuff and I don't
want it you obviously do would you like
the stuff now and I'm like yes yes
please send me the stuff send me cd-roms
send me piles of floppy send me whatever
you want to and I'll put him up on text
files comm and text files comm grew and
grew and grew and and I became known
whether I wanted to as a historian as an
archivist as a librarian I did not go to
school for these things I went to school
with a film degree okay I graduated from
high school this is very true this is
not me being funny I graduated from high
school with a 1.7 grade point average
alright that is very hard to do without
shooting the place up
but I did it I did it and I went to
Emerson College in Boston because the
buildings look nice and I and my parents
said you know you can't move more than a
hundred miles away from us you know just
for Transport's sake so I moved a
hundred miles away and so I moved to
Boston and I didn't ask you Munich
Asian's concentration and film where I
learned about being on the radio and and
I did newspapers and I found that I was
good at speaking and I found that it's
gonna be on the radio and I was a radio
DJ and that was a newspaper our educate
at Oriole cartoonist I was getting all
these crazy things right and I graduated
with that 2.1 grade point average
totally investing myself in that place
yeah so so the thing was was that I was
just not a good student but I was
somebody who cared about what he did and
when I started to like you know do this
whole thing online and really throwing
myself in online I became this this
weirdly respectable fellow and so it
turns out like you can like kind of like
sneak your way in through the back into
respectability
I have zero credentials all my
credentials are Street right all street
credentials they'll remember me for that
but no no no I'm not so good with the
reports I can write and I'm young enough
or I should say I'm old enough sorry
that when I brought a laptop to school
they put in my permanent record that
they assumed I was cheating so that's
about that period of time and you know
so no Twitter no nothing just just
yelling at people and so anyway in this
new respectable guys that I now live in
right I work here and I work at the
Internet Archive which is located here
in San Francisco I still live in New
York my official title is free-range
archivist which sounds like some sort of
weird enemy and a first-person shooter
but I am so I'm a free-range archivist
software curator and I work for it it
looks like this but it shouldn't if you
go up to the top and it says click on
beta it looks like this this is what it
should look like and it looks fantastic
and it's a fantastic place you know it's
it's it's one of these things where you
know I interacted with the Internet
Archive like a lot of people either
using the wayback machine unaware that I
was on the Internet
archive or because I wanted a movie or
something and at the time I was
downloading a lot of stuff throughout my
30s because I was like it's all gonna go
away because of all these lessons I've
learned so I'm gonna disappear don't
trust anybody and I remember that day I
tried to take on the Internet Archive
she doesn't know about the day I tried
to download the Internet Archive don't
do this don't do this don't do this
don't do this it's like watching a
hamster try to chew a baseball doesn't
work does not work the first time I
grabbed it and I was like oh look the
basic file is one point eight gigabytes
well that's everything today I gave up
but this thing was full of stuff and
having walked at stacks I will tell you
it has a lot of things and it has even
more things than that and that's when
you think you found everything you
realize you're only in the first room
and so it's it's this amazing collection
of human culture especially online
culture but also all sorts of culture
anything that's been gifted for the
moment with being transferred to a
digital form is mostly welcome on the
Internet Archive and so it really
reflects a whole bunch of amazing
cultural pieces of humanity and I love
walking it and working there I have
either over seen this number is rough
but I have overseen or personally
uploaded about 2% of what's in the
archive which is a scary number I will
admit how did I get to that okay well
I'll talk about the moment here's some
of where my stuff is this is located
inside of a church and each one of those
is about one petabyte of disk space
sitting inside of a church if you
haven't been to the church go to church
come to church it's one of the finest
secular testimonies to data in the world
it's beautiful you got to go there okay
so if you look for archive.org there's a
way to go there and if it's not weird
enough for you it's full of little
statues I think the greatest thing and
that's why it's really nice that you're
all here with the interval is that OMG
should always be accompanied by WTF in
the world right I think you need to do
that right the Vatican has that too or
you're like oh look at this what is up
with that
you walk in here like this is amazing
what is that thing why are they doing it
this way this is oh my god a robot is
drawing computers okay well if you work
at the archive for three years you get a
statue of yourself and I'm happy to say
that I work at the archive for three
years so this is when I stopped this
this the moment when this little guy
joined the world is when I stopped
referring to the archive as them and
started really referring to them as us
and it takes a long time for a kid who
loses his parents the way I did to build
that kind of trust but yeah so I'm in
that family cuz they made a little doll
of me so I there is no good life advice
there I don't know about any other place
that builds a little statue of you but
if they do trust them they're probably
pretty nice it takes a lot of effort to
draw the little statue of you I had to
give her like 19 pictures and little Ted
Nelson's living back there um and he's
holding little floppy disks and he's
happy he's a good guy I like him um you
know the Internet Archive like I said is
just loaded with amazing stuff it's it's
the wonder of it of course right is and
I've said this before when he's not in
the room but I'll say it when he's in
the room the reason the reason I'm so
pleased about the Internet Archive is
because it's a perfect example of
somebody getting really rich and then
not being a [ __ ] right I mean really
seriously how many times have you seen
somebody just strike it big in some way
and the first thing he does is oh I
don't know buy a 78 million dollar
ridiculous-looking munch and somewhere
in LA that Kanye was voting on why not
but this just happened and I'm just
looking at it like really that's what
you needed 78 million now if instead you
look at this 78 million dollars like
that good really um that's what I'm so
amazed by because the Internet Archive
needed to exist at the time that it
existed technically it needed to exist
20 years earlier but there was nobody
there and nobody thought it was needed
and everyone thought it would all work
and now we have it so that's why that's
it really seriously you can't overstate
it it's nice to work for a place where
people can't overstate things I can't
overstate how much of our online history
would be lost without the unit archives
starting when it did right it just
wouldn't exist we just completely lose
it it was gone it was gray I think there
were some links that were not grey on
Netscape founded Microsoft in some sort
of browser Explorer
there was a server we just have this
fuzzy thing we would all be relying on
like poorly done screenshots and books
and that would be it so you know the
Internet Archive has all of this
grabbing that's going on and also a lot
of people don't know this at night it
actually is like this so when people are
on it it does this it's amazing it plays
all this music and then all this sparks
come you can't be in the building when
this happens though you got a run we all
run we all look at all the lights but
then everyone gets a copy of their it's
fantastic all right so the things called
the web in the eye blink we'll talk a
little bit at the web all right so for a
lot of people the internet like kind of
is the web right it's kind of the web
and there are various people who have
memories of transport before then right
like so San Francisco has been many
things but right now it's just this kind
of tech bro goulash that's at culture
war with itself and is also trying to
change the world and has perfected a way
for tech Bros to drive each other
everywhere but but the thing is is that
of course it's been many things before
right I worked for a dot bomb company
called digital island in 2000 and and I
came here and I was like what are you
all doing because there was companies
called purple gorilla without seriously
purple gorilla was a travel so here's
the thing when you have to say was uh
something like if someone goes
International Business Machines was uh
ok come for it a place that made
machines for business internationally
that called itself IBM and it was called
big blue because they all wore blue
suits you'd be like I get it
purple gorilla was a travel site running
somewhere near the Transamerica building
that eventually died okay fantastic and
all the names just just you know just
metal fruit you know just like some type
of metal some sort of fruit or whatever
these all these hybrid names and now
they just figure it out well we can make
that first part one letter and
everything's cool
but anyway um the web right people will
usually call the web about the moment
that we're all able to use browsers you
know sort of in 1989 but not really more
like 1992 1993 and that we get up to now
right and so the web has several
attributes that I have discovered over
the time of watching it I was very lucky
I got to use the NCSA browser
downloading it I was working as a temp
at MIT so it had a nice fat pipe which I
don't even want to think of how little
pipe it was but we would download it to
this little thing and I would browse the
web you know this is when the web could
be defined as a couple hundred sites and
so I can speak from authority right I
can speak from authority okay so the web
is ridiculous
ridiculous the web is a fast talker it
will convince you things very quickly
and get you onto its side very quickly
about everything from its outlook in the
world to why other people are terrible
or other people are great it really
really really can snow you also the web
is unendingly bored not boring bored it
wants one more thing it wants lots of
cool things it wants to do them now it
doesn't want to think about what there
was before as much and it's really
really excited if you can actually go
back and buy some things that's the web
right that's the web as I've kind of
perceived it right these web sites that
come and go these events that come and
go terms that live bloom and burn out
within the course of a three weeks right
and and and Twitter has not helped that
right Twitter just basically went
kerosene and just poured it all on there
and said stop thinking so much stop
thinking so long with your long talks
everyone see today by the way that
medium invented blogging today that
everyone catch that medium said great
Jews we've discovered that there's an
area between doing a tweet he seriously
said this I'm not kidding we found a
spot between tweeting and long-form so
you can put down your thoughts in a
quicker way it was like being sold a
doughnut as a brand new form factor for
the for bread it's sweeter it's hand
held a bowl I have changed your night
and you don't even know why anyway but
this is the way the kind of the web is
right you go back if you look at things
like this is netscape netscape which is
gonna change everything right and the
first thing you noticed looking at it is
like well first of all very little
javascript but second and second of all
no real ads but but kind of third of all
you have you know buttons and it says
netscape now and that's because it's
time for you to get onto netscape you
know because if you go onto the other
browser your web experience will be
different so they were doing this this
horseshit all friggin from the beginning
right one place one place there was nut
scape store they used to sell browsers
and and you could you know learn about
what was going on right this is the very
first e-commerce site on the net this is
the beginning and what you would do is
you would go to Pizza Hut you would tell
it your name and street address in your
phone number then they would call you
back and sell you a pizza
this is it this is it
this is where all the crap happens this
is it this is the forum this is when it
all goes south this is one all gets
stupid this is when everything turns
into how can we sell you everything
interstitials pop-ups everything Thank
You Pizza Hut and again you know you're
talking about these very small numbers
in the beginning and then things just
growing and growing and growing and all
this time here the web is an experiment
it's an idea
right it's bored it wants to try new
things let's look a coffee cup a coffee
maker up to a webcam let's have cats on
it let's talk about fan fiction if any
of you have been watching the Geo cities
pages I've been having go by you know
most of them are fan fiction you know in
speaking of geo cities actually geo
cities was shut down
utterly in 2009 and in doing so it was a
closing of a chapter of the web and the
most annoying part for me was that a lot
of people were like good riddance and it
became very cool to say well glad were
over that and now we're gonna get to I
don't know the real stuff I'm not sure
but-but-but geo cities enabled people to
come on to the web for free essentially
and use up to ten megabytes of carefully
crafted space to tell their story with
no limits no sense of requirements no
having a committee no begging they could
call in and they could just have a
website and for some people this may
have been the largest audience their
genetic line had ever reached because
they never had that speak you know
full-color sometimes sound having to
have all of this amazing design work
that you had to hack out so when it went
down I got or when I found out it was
going down I got very angry and remember
you know just for perspective this is
the Geocities cage which held nine
terabytes
so that's what 9 terabytes looks like in
1999 um and so Geocities was like trying
to keep itself up you know it was trying
to do the right thing and then it was
purchased by Yahoo who just threw it
into a car trunk and set it on fire over
the course the next bunch of years we
figured out that in the last year of its
existence it had nobody assigned to it
just floating and at that time it was
the two hundred and twelfth most viewed
website in the planet at the time of its
death so just walk away from that so you
know Geocities was this Harbinger for
people and it bothered me it bothered me
so much that it would go away and I said
there should be a team of people who
rush in and make a copy because you
can't argue about the historical
sanctity of a building once it's burned
to the ground
I mean you can but you seem a little
lame like a little behind the times so I
said we have to do something about it
and I didn't know I was wandering out of
this world right where we were
discovering how completely transient how
dumb this this whole setup was that it
was built on sand it was an experiment
that become vital it was like doing a
MakerBot project and then plugging it
into the heating system of your house
you just were like oh my god we depend
on this made-up thing and as we've
discovered in the last two or three
years there are been some shortcuts
afoot not for anyone's fault it was just
we were just let's keep going let's keep
going and one of the things that keeps
going is let's keep throwing out the old
you know the web was never really
designed to be permanent they want it to
be permanent and we talked of that
language you know a URL but a URL is a
universal resource locator it is not a
permanent record it's just a way to get
to things fast but nothing there
necessarily was ever imbued with a way
to end up anywhere else at the same time
and so it just it's just a fundamental
flaw it's nobody's fault but we're here
it's time to like redo that right it
really is time that we do that um but I
said okay well let's do it by screaming
and doing profanity so Archive team
which is an archive teen org is a group
of activist archivists
who rush into websites that are going
down not asking too many questions
giving the finger to everybody and
taking as many copies as we can as fast
as possible for they delete it and then
storing it away because the conversation
ends when it's down for instance I don't
know how many of you here's the thing I
started this in 2009 it's now 2015 it is
a war it is a constant frontline war I
don't think I had all these gray hairs
so for instance I can tell you all that
today I am aware that google just
announced that any blogger accounts that
have nudity that is considered pure
ayant
or explicit will be taken away on March
26th unless it demonstrates artistic
educational or historical merit to which
you go what that's that's like oh no
it's like somebody shooting you and just
being like no I really thought this
through like I just thought I don't I
don't know what it's supposed to effect
you for like but but Siri but seriously
like Google did this today right and
I've often said the problem is people
thought that Google was gonna be our
archive it looked like it didn't it
right in the beginning they were like
sucking everything up they were taking
books they were making them Anna turned
out that Google is an archive like a
supermarket is a food museum they will
throw everything out if they want to
right so it we just had this whole
digital vellum thing where where the
really really smart old man who works
for one of the largest leaders of data
in the world has just said we shouldn't
leave as much data so yes anyway so if
you go to archive team.org you'll see
that we have anywhere from 20 to 30
simultaneous projects we're downloading
every old FTP site we're going in and
we're downloading old photo sites that
we think are going down or podcast sites
or fanfiction sites that have gotten
into a fight if we see too many errors
on a website someone will tell us we'll
grab a copy and it's just be sure and
any other things and it wouldn't be
possible without the Internet Archive
who we store a lot of things
with right we wouldn't have the space we
pull in about 400 gigabytes of data a
day just going around and being like
that's at risk that's at risk that's it
that guy's stupid let's just take all
his stuff and put it somewhere safe
because he's gonna screw up and he does
he does um make it sound personal I'll
be I'll be less okay this this talk will
be less stupid um alright so um I'm
giving it two more seconds one more
giggle there we go okay good alright
here's the secret right life is a lossy
format we do not actually have it within
us to store everything you know I have
the word hoarder thrown at me a lot and
that's adorable it's cute I mean it's
nice you helped I guess sort of yeah but
the thing is is we don't know what's
important and if it's relatively easy
and non-disruptive to one's life through
organized action to take a snapshot
knowing that things will go away later I
think it's a meaningful worthwhile thing
let me tell you about how life is a
lossy format my Uncle Sam who was in the
previous picture now Uncle Sam there is
wearing long sleeves the reason Uncle
Sam's living long sleeves cuz he didn't
want us and I didn't know about the
number on his arm that he got and he got
the number on his arm when he was hauled
into a camp and he did something which I
did not expect this old man who was just
a really cranky guy in our house to do
which was he scaled a fence and got out
he then dressed up as a priest went
under a false name which he kept for the
rest of his life and died like you so
many of his relatives should have
shoveling snow after an argument with
his wife at 80 right so the thing is is
that's my grandmother who I never met um
you know my family tree has seven black
spots because there's seven people
cousins great cousins in my case who
they were hauled the family was hauled
up so quickly and died in such a way
that we don't know their names so
there's no record we just know there
were seven children born in our family
we don't know anything about them
they're just like so I know about loss
and I know about like how
just as a natural thing lose things and
it's also always good to have
perspective you know when I got into a
screaming phone battle with one of the
founders of of ello because I thought
here's the thing I thought wouldn't have
been great to be able to go back you
know like 2003 and 4 and like be able to
scream at Mark Zuckerberg face for a
little bit like you're gonna really mess
the world up and and just do it anyway I
thought I would do that with ello just
in case ello didn't appreciate that but
I was and I totally appreciate that that
was very very poor management
personality interpersonal and and and
and and both resource management skills
in time but buppa buppa but we had a
really great conversation it was pretty
good and he said okay come back in six
months and we'll see where we are
turns out nobody cares about lol die but
but the thing is is that I recognize
also that um without these like this day
Trias that we collect we don't let the
next generation make the decision we've
made the decision for them I hate being
the gatekeeper I hate being the one that
says out of these hundred books these
forty get to live I don't like that job
I don't want that job I don't think we
should have that job if we can avoid it
right a really good example this are
time capsules right time capsules of
this very interesting thing we do we
build things and put things in them that
we think are important in the hope that
people will never meet we'll look at
them that is a very odd thing why do we
do that
and I brought this up because you know
I'm here at the long now foundation and
we have this this this whole dream that
they have to make us think outside of
our lives to to to go you know here's my
definition of the long now foundation is
a bunch of us going dan tenet out and a
thousand years people go dad
that's pretty much all right so so
there's all these little dent in an ant
dance everywhere right they have all of
these time capsules that they put around
you know all of them are interesting
just to me a lot of the thing about time
capsules is the time capsule is actually
a lot more about the burying than it is
about the retrieval it's a lot more
about hey let's put this stuff on the
ground because we're going there too and
and it should be a nice place when it
comes back out again and so you know
each one of these it's like this is a
branded time capsule right I mean you
got other branded time capsules or like
you know to be opened
you know 1958 we're really excited and
when it works it's actually kind of
exciting right I mean a 1795 you know
time capsule that had Paul Revere and
and and and and and when these things
are revealed this I have them be out of
order by the way but here's a good
example like a time capsule it's only
about 30 years old and you pull it out
you're like yay look at all this stupid
stuff but here's the thing right this is
the moment I'm talking about this is us
right we're here now stuff flies in the
sky that shouldn't have we have killer
robots in the skies we're kind of fine
with that
we have weird computers in our pocket
that talk to other people about where to
meet them for sex and we have this this
this world that we live in of miracles
and wonderment right David Hasselhoff is
still here just like he was here and and
then we're like what are we doing what
did these people think this is what was
going to look at this like what did they
think was going to be here now like how
is that gonna change it that's that's
kind of what fascinates me about that
piece right here's the coins by the way
so these are really old coins we have
the Museum of Fine Arts so it's the
museum isn't that great we're gonna look
at it and it's amazing we can look at
these they've they've put them in there
to be careful and everything's cool and
they're gonna be valuable and we'll
stare at them and we're heroes um but
there's also this kind of a deal here is
a what happened here this is to me more
realistic about what's gonna happen a
school Minnesota puts a a cornerstone
it's full of a time capsule in it and
then they decide they're going to
rip up that building for a parking lot
it's supposed to be in there for like 50
or 60 years parking lot ten years later
so they grab it and they pull it up and
what do they find it's broken water got
in its destroyed the images of it are
all these wrecked
I put syringes in it but okay fine what
were you thinking who did you hate
because in the future gonna be so germ
phobic that if someone stabs it we just
zapped them with a laser but because
none of the antibiotics work so like
this is a Pepsi can which was supposed
to get I don't know tell you that Pepsi
was also open then and and and and and
it's gone right and and here's a
videotape that also was gonna have a
little bit of a problem trying to
explain something and this schmuck I
only say this because they were talking
about how they were going to leave
Philly throw this stuff out because it
was just garbage to them it was
literally garbage and I wonder if all of
that is gonna happen right I'm gonna
switch forward to me again
this is me as a miserable teen so this
isn't quite the horns picture but it's
not quite the little kid with the
Holocaust survivor and this is a picture
is the whole thing called bursh on the
idea of a teen who gets a picture they
don't want to be in it's called burr
Shawn it's a thing we're doing it now
it'll be dead in three months don't
worry but it's basically the idea of
like you know when you take a picture of
a teen and they don't want to be there
and they're like that burr Shawn anyway
here's the thing I was really sad I was
vaguely suicidal I felt really sad about
things in the world but there was one
thing I loved and that was reader
service cards and reader service cards
in the back of a magazine they don't do
this anymore and you would circle the
the numbers of the things you wanted to
know about right you wanted to know like
more about this power strip in this
thing and it would say Oh circle 143 on
the reader service card so I circled all
of them
and every day every day the beautiful
world of the computer would mail me at
my house and tell me about things and I
kept it and I have I mean looks better
okay this is me more I cleaned up but
these are all things that were sent to
me by companies that died immediately on
contact like like like you know like
pouring water on a hot skillet just gone
boom right but there's so much beauty in
it here's an Atari computer that never
came out called the 1450 xld I've held
the resin model that this was actually a
picture of this no computer there's you
know the Columbia VP one of the family
of lugga bulls there's not much
information about the Columbia VB I'll
tell you that all right it is amazing to
use an Atari more than you could ever
imagine
Mega Wars was a CompuServe multiplayer
game in 1980s that if you notice he's on
a keyboard and they're fighting each
other and I don't know what she's doing
there's no enemy there are you okay lady
do you have any glasses
um he's fighting this bad thing you
should anyway so um you know in each one
of these cases this was this is the way
out of suicidal thoughts for a kid right
this dream right this is a CompuServe ad
that's a pretty good CompuServe ad that
can if if you need a signal for like
maybe you should [ __ ] stick around
it's gonna get pretty awesome that's a
pretty good one this by the way is
exactly what facebook is like just so
you know it's pretty much it you're
alone and a thing is absorbing you in
shadow it's hard to feel bad about
making fun of a company that made a
million dollars while I made fun of them
um so anyway that you know here but
here's the thing right so these guys are
beautiful shots of a world that didn't
exist but I fell in love with it and it
kept me out of it and it's why I save it
even though it's been thirty years and
I'll put it online these are all on
archive.org so I ended up being a happy
kid now Wilson minor you might remember
remember he talked about you know a tool
and I thought that it was neat so I'm
gonna tell you quickly about a tool that
I have I know I'm getting close I know
getting close they prepped me they
talked me through they rubbed me with
like oils to say come on don't don't
don't make this go too long so let's
talk very quickly about life again
this guy is named slug slug created
space war if you go to the Computer
History Museum on most weekends slug
will come and kick your ass on the
machine behind him which is the machine
that space war was invented on in 1951
61 my apologies so you can go there 1961
and the guy who invented that computer
history will come and kick your ass this
is very important because that is how
constricted our online history is like
the web is this little you know when I
say it the web is an eye blink in the
history of humanity right it's like
5,000 years from like oh my god a rock
to kim kardashian and then it's it's
like one millisecond to this right and
and and also i for some people who care
there's no hover hand I touched him I
touch the man I love him again life is a
lossy format but software is not quite a
lossy format it likes to be completely
together and that's where luck comes in
so there's a thing I've been working on
for about three years this is what I
started working on with Brewster hired
me one of things he said to me was I
would like for you you know we've been
doing pretty good with the web we've
been ok with the web we've been in
pretty good books we're actually doing
good with music we have a lot of music
we have a whole lot of movies but what
about software how do we do things with
software and the reason that movies and
music persist is because we can play
them and not only can we play them but
we can play them like nothing like if
I'm like oh god listen how terrible this
band is the time from man what are you
talking about - you're right they suck
can be like five seconds right that's
amazing you're not amazing like you
forget it like oh my god look what this
cat is doing on top of writing this this
Roomba boom you're looking at cat on
Roomba the world's a little dumber but
you did it two seconds and so why don't
we have that with software this is the
moment when my mind got blown right this
is a game called smurf rescue from
ColecoVision right let's go back to it
and in it you pilot a smurf he has to
jump over those things and meet
Smurfette it's very simple it's about
the ColecoVision
but over the course of two and a half
years we got it to run in the browser in
JavaScript and here's the thing about
that why like first of all why would you
do that abomination against all of man
and Lord and okay we so the thing is is
that right now the way to get to
everybody is the web the way that we get
there is using a browser and the thing
in browsers that has not been destroyed
by Larry Ellison is JavaScript right
Java scripts in everything like it or
not and technology has been done to turn
JavaScript into the end run for a
compiler without going through the full
technical details because they're all up
there the point is we were able to take
a emulator called
mes s the multi emulator super system
that has 1600 platforms everything from
ghent the Sega Genesis and 2600 to the
ColecoVision
and be able to make it play stuff in
your browser basically in full speed the
first time we got it running it ran at
14% speed we had it in 70% speed within
two weeks we had 24 systems running at a
hundred percent speed and it's going on
like that right we have been able to do
all these different systems we have old
stuff from Atari all these are running
in JavaScript here's a chess system from
1979 here spy versus spy we've even
gotten to the point so you know that's
that's neat and it's up there if you go
to archive that or go to software boom
you could say to somebody I can't
believe someone made a game about this
there it is ok so from there it gets
really weird and scary because now once
we've been able to make a machine run in
a machine where do you go from there
well we have something I called the
emulator D this is Windows running
inside of a browser and we actually have
it booting up so that's JavaScript and
we've actually gotten PPP to work so
that the browser can connect through PPP
out of the browser into the internet so
it's connecting to text files comm using
the mosaic the the mosaic browser and is
able to connect so it's a 1994 browser
inside of a 1993 operating system that's
running inside of a 2015 browser that's
running inside of a 2000
13 operating system right we're here now
um now just to be clear the current
internet does not like you uh uh
whitehouse.gov is like what are you
forsooth i cometh with the Magna Carta
to bring us to you but that's what we
you know so okay fine I understand that
but the best part is it actually leaves
something in the log so it'll actually
say well 16-bit windows three one
netscape 1.0 is stopped by that'll blow
your metrics right the heck out and even
more importantly than that you know it's
funny how the world works it turns out
the most important thing you look at at
wha the most important thing we've put
up twenty five thousand software
packages and consoles all perfectly
running and everyone wants to play
Oregon Trail but it's true you go to org
you go to this our site and you can play
Oregon Trail and in fact is it having an
effect yes here are students on all
these screens playing Oregon Trail on
our site I had a teacher send this to me
when he told me this they used to have
the entire class circle around one
computer and they would all shout out
what needed to be done now they walk
into the computer room and they all put
Oregon Trail on all of them and all the
kids are learning about the Oregon Trail
through our archive so there's actually
some really amazing things happening and
I should be proud of all this I am proud
of this but the thing is is like I said
it's less about the tool because it's
neat right it's amazing
please go use it wonderful thing and
while you're there donate to the
Internet Archive please but you know
it's it's it's it's less about the fact
that I worked on that tool then I grew
up through this area of tragedy and
weirdness and I found my space and I
built it and I moved from there and
other things and I found a kindred
spirit with a few more bucks and I was
able to work on the dream of the thing I
was working on and together we created
this thing that then builds the dreams
of these children and other people so
this kid is using a computer that was
made you know eight minutes ago although
it's a public school eight years ago and
then he is using a computer program from
20
years ago is this if it's nothing just
booting it up you can play it anywhere
and that's more important to me right
it's that's where we see all of these
things come together and it's like if at
any time of that I had stumbled or given
up on myself or I hated myself where I
ended myself none of these things would
be in the same way and so it's just so
important to let people know there's
people who are on this camera right
they're the ones I'm also worried about
you know 10 15 20 years 50 years I'm
sorry I died but I was pretty cool glad
to meet you this way and they should
feel like I have dreams there are things
that matter to me and it's not bad to
have those things so nothing is
permanent so love it while it's here
right trust very little but what you do
trust trust it entirely believe in it
right I now believe in the Internet
Archive I now believe as a family member
in it and what it's doing that's goals
I'm doing that making it happen right
and you are responsible for your destiny
but you're not actually alone right your
destiny is actually shared you know you
take care of yourself but take care of
everyone who's a part of your life alone
right and so so this is all I'm asking
right so doesn't even ask why I have
wings but this is the streets of Belfast
don't walk down the streets of Belfast
if the Black Angel of Death I've done it
it's old don't do it I can't suggest it
anyway so all I care about you know this
is the life that we're getting we have
all these things that are both silly and
weird we've all chosen in many ways to
use this easily bored talkative stupid
thing and it's a wonderful life and we
should enjoy it we should think about
what people are going to take from it
after us we should remember that we're
the temporary caretaker of this chain
but we should enjoy ourselves while
we're here and that's all I wanted to
say in the night link thank you very
much name is Jason Scott
two minutes over hardly hardly a crime
it was it was it was worth it it was
what did we do to you
was there pointment involved I'm not
there when there were own myths there
was the remember that so the other thing
is do you want to actually you want to
do the transition I'll make you work on
a keyboard since you're so good at the
keyboard so 2% of the Internet Archive
is your direct your name is all over it
as you go to all these things so you're
gonna drag that browser window window
into winter winter to the right drag it
to the right criticize my pronunciation
later there you go sort of work so this
is a funky little game called Robotron
does anyone remember Robotron excellent
so running in the archive so we wanted
to do a demo of how this how this works
and we want to do it on our big screen
because we've got an awesome big screen
here's the deal with Robotron you were
the last living creature a living robot
on earth you're a warrior and there are
nuclear families who wander around and
they are a beset upon by endless sets of
creatures and normally you would have to
you had two joysticks this was made in
1983 I believe 82 and you one would do
nothing but move you and the other one
would do nothing but fire so you would
do this and it was brutal it would throw
40 50 80 enemies at you what you gonna
make me do this do it fire fire at them
and then you want to pick up the members
of the family to save them oh come on
and then boom and then next one but as
you can see each wall and then each one
of these is a nightmarish beset upon
it's like Day of the Dead but every one
of the zombies is on a Vespa scooter and
and look out and so you're trying to
like shoot at them but it's gonna be
even worse because you're gonna be
paired up with a human being or you're
gonna play the what weird things can
Jason say to me while I'm talking to him
game which is even more interesting
doesn't cost you a quarter anyway oh and
by the way this is all in JavaScript
inside of a browser inside of the
Internet Archive I can't believe people
were actually caring about the fate of
that little guy no the future
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you